hey everybody and welcome to the
long-awaited second part of my
over-the-board tournament guide
so a couple of months ago um as some of
you probably saw i released a video that
was sort of an overview of
over-the-board chess where i talked
about stuff like how to register for a
tournament
uh how to find chess clubs in your area
how to become a united states chess
federation or
international chess federation member
and i sort of talked about all these uh
annoying nitpicky things that you need
to know in order to play your first
over-the-board chess tournament because
you know over-the-board chess is coming
back a lot of people who learn chess
online are interested in playing over
the board chess but
are totally understandably a little bit
worried about not knowing the procedure
or simply not knowing how to register so
you know if you didn't watch that first
video i normally don't do this but go
ahead and watch that because
i think uh these videos should be
watched in sequence because in this
video
i will be giving you
the insider's look into everything that
you should know in order to actually
play an over-the-board tournament so
um i'm assuming that you've watched the
first video and you have essentially
registered for an over-the-board
tournament you've made a membership
you've become a uscf member you come to
the actual tournament that's held in
some hotel or convention center but you
know nothing about
how a tournament actually functions and
mainly um i know that a lot of people
are worried about not knowing
uh over-the-board etiquette what is it
actually like to play an over-the-board
game what what are the rules what do you
have to know
uh in order to sort of not make a fool
of yourself
and in this video i'm going to try to
share as much as i can in order to make
you completely comfortable
uh playing an over-the-board tournament
and hopefully by the end of it you're
going to feel like a pro and any fear
that you may have of
misbehaving or doing something that the
pros don't do
will hopefully vanish now i want to warn
you this is going to be a really rambly
video i have a sheet here that has all
of the information that i want to talk
about so i'm just going to let myself
ramble all right and um
when i get to the part about actually
playing uh and sitting in front of the
board i'm gonna tilt my camera down i've
never done this before so please forgive
any technical issues and
uh hopefully you'll find something
useful in all of the rambling okay so
once again let's say that you watched
the first video you have chosen a
tournament
uh the tournament's held at the hilton
hotel
in some city you come to the hotel
everything is good your name is on the
registration lists
what happens so
i'm going to kind of walk you through
a uh hypothetical day at a tournament
and it starts with you coming
in the morning let's say you've looked
up on the website the first round is at
11 am now it's always a good idea to
come to the tournament hall early if
you're staying at the same hotel where
the tournament is held uh make sure
you're coming down before the first
round
you know 15 20 minutes earlier just to
make sure that your name is on the
registration list
uh just to make sure you know where the
tournament is going to be held and
just to verify that everything is fine
so generally in american tournaments
uh the pairings uh by which i mean the
the sheet of paper that tells you who
you're gonna be playing next uh in the
vast majority of cases that is going to
be a sheet
that is up on the wall on the side of
the tournament hall that you're playing
in and you're going to see that
everybody's going to be clustered around
the pairing sheet
some tournaments um and this has been
more more common lately
have uh online pairings
so uh there will be you know on the
tournament website there will be a link
to a website or to a to a subsection of
the website that will have the pairings
and you can check that in advance of the
round
and that's going to contain a digitized
version of what you're going to see on
the wall but you're always going to see
the pairing sheet on the wall what does
the pairing shoe look like uh how do you
decipher so i
you know this is a pretty impromptu
video so everything i've prepared i've
kind of done by hand so what a pairing
sheet will look like very approximately
is is something like this and i've just
hand written this uh just just now
so you're gonna have a
you know you're gonna see the board
number you're gonna see the player who
has the white pieces and it's gonna be
labeled last name rating and the player
of the black pieces last name rating
that's all that you need to know so all
you need to do is you need to find your
last name you need to find the board
number very important
and um
you need to find the color that you're
playing with and again that's going to
be easily labeled you don't need to
worry about that
um and
then you have to find uh your board
number in the tournament hall and sit
down behind the appropriate pieces
you might be wondering whether that's
hard it's not hard you're going to see
all the board numbers labeled the
tournament hall might be pretty big
if at any point you get lost you're not
sure where your board number is what you
always want to do is ask a tournament
director or a td the vast majority of
tournaments big and small have uniformed
tournament directors or worse comes to
us you can go to the people at the
registration desk whoever you can find
tournament organizer it's in my
experience if you're not sure where
you're playing it's much better to just
ask there's no shame in that even as a
gm uh in new tournaments i sometimes
don't know where to go or where my
section is
uh so by all means that's why tournament
directors are there do not hesitate to
ask them to help you find your board for
example
so um
i'm going to very quickly pan out to a
new scene here
and show you what a what a tournament
hall normally looks like and i did that
in the previous video
uh but but i've just searched the world
open is the largest open tournament in
the u.s held every year in philadelphia
and you can see here what what a
tournament hall normally looks like
these are maybe not the best photos but
you can kind of see there's there's rows
um and the boards are
normally with kova they're they're a
little bit more spaced out now but you
kind of get the point it's a large
tournament hall and and you'll have
board number labels on on all of the
boards
um this is maybe a more realistic
realistic portrayal okay so you found
your board you sit down
what happens then well first of all
you got to make sure that you grab a
score sheet and score sheets should be
available at the front of the room uh
scoresheet is what you essentially keep
notation on and in all uscf rated events
all official events you have to keep
notation or you have to write down the
moves unfortunately i don't have a an
actual score sheet handy but i'll use a
sheet of paper as a stand-in and sort of
show you what you normally have to do
and this is where i'm going to pan the
camera down so you're gonna you're not
gonna see me but you're going to see a
chessboard and a clock and i'll
basically imitate a score sheet so let
me do that right now
and they're gonna watch me
probably drop the camera or something to
that effect so i hope this works
or i'll have to re-record the whole
thing all right
let's tilt this camera down
just so you can see well you can see my
mouse that's great
i think you can see the board i think
this is good
yeah
all right so um let me make sure
actually that you can see the clock as
well you can see part of the clock
see the score sheet okay i think i know
what i need to do
see this is the actual fun part of the
video
all right there we go
this is better i think
there we go this is
great um
so you'll have to not not see me for a
little while i hope you'll live
all right so you come to the board now
um at this point i want to make it very
clear that most tournaments in the u.s
do not provide boards this is actually
very important so
what i would do if i were you
and you want to play over the board
tournaments regularly i would go on
amazon and get yourself a tournament set
and get yourself a nice chest clock i
would highly recommend the clock that i
have here this is called the dgt
north america clock it's very
customizable it's easy to use
and it's durable and it's not too
expensive a tournament set you can get a
nice set of weighted plastic pieces for
about 30 bucks and i think this clock
costs about 50 bucks i'll have all the
links down in the description below so
don't worry about writing any of it down
i'll make sure to provide some amazon
links
or links to the official website of
these things but make sure
um to get yourself a tournament set of
pieces and a clock and bring that to
tournaments normally the website of the
tournament is going to tell you whether
clocks and boards are provided but in
about 90 of cases unless it's a
sort of invitational tournament or some
special small event uh it's not provided
and when in doubt you want to make sure
that you bring this stuff i've
been in tournaments where neither player
has a board and then you've got to find
a tournament director or borrow someone
said it takes all the fun out of the
tournament okay so this wooden set is
not representative of what you normally
see in tournaments this is just the set
that i'm that i'm currently using
so you come to the board let's say that
this is a scoresheet a score sheet is
going to be smaller
and uh it's very very uh
self-explanatory you should have an
extra pen or pencil whatever you want to
use
a scoresheet is going to have a sort of
top header that that has you know white
black name of the tournament you want to
fill all that in you don't have to fill
it in what you actually only have to do
is fill out the moves and then it's
going to have
sort of a a section and it's going to
have numbered moves
and it's going to have a space for
white's move and black's move
this is absolutely not how it actually
looks
so
um you will have to set the clock if
boards and clocks are not provided to
the time control that is announced on
the website and it will be announced
again before the start of the round
um if you have if you get yourself a dgt
north america clock and i promise this
is they did not sponsor me this is you
know just what i think uh
the best clock in my experience on the
back of it
uh you have all of the settings and
there's a manual set so let's say for
the for the sake of this video that the
time control in the tournament that you
are playing in let's make it very simple
let's say it's just an hour and a half
uh for the whole game and that's not a
very common time control sometimes you
have two hours for the whole game
uh there's also something called
increment you might if you watch some of
the top tournaments you might hear that
word thrown around in increment just
means a certain amount of time that is
added after a move is executed and this
clock does allow you to set increments
so i'm just going to show you here two
is the manual set
um and ooh looks like
i need to change the batteries and then
that second thing is the increment so if
there's a five second increment
what happens is and okay i didn't set
one for black but it doesn't matter
you press start the clock and when you
make a move and you press the clock five
seconds are added to your clock normally
you have a 30 second increment press
press okay
let me reset the clock to an hour 30
with no increment
i hope the clock doesn't die while i'm
making the video that would be just my
luck
now uh this is a little bit obscure but
the player who has the black pieces
generally gets to choose which side the
clock is on obviously if you're
right-handed it's more convenient to
have the clock on your right side so you
can press it with your right hand but if
you are playing black you are allowed to
move the clock between right and left
side i don't think this is a formal rule
but it is generally accepted among chess
players black has the choice of where to
put the clock let's just put the clock
on the right side for the sake of this
video
and let's say that
you know your name is john smith and
you've got the white pieces you adjust
the pieces neatly before the start of
the game you can touch the pieces do
whatever you want before the clocks are
started before the first round the
tournament director generally makes some
announcements what the time control is
maybe announces some of the top players
in the open section and then you will
always hear the signal please start your
clocks do never start your opponent's
clock
uh or your own clock i'll explain that
in a second until that announcement
uh until that announcement has been made
okay and once the announcement is made
if your opponent is not there yet all
right if your opponent is there you
shake hands of course again in kova
times normally that looks like a fist
bump or no handshake at all
and black starts white's clock since
white move first black presses the play
button and as you can see the clock has
started to tick the game has begun
now very importantly the rule is that
you have to make a move on the board and
press the clock and then write it down
it used to be the case that you could
write down the move first and then
execute it some people like to do that
in scholastic tournaments there'd be a
lot of peaking
sometimes uh you know
my opponent would p i used to do this i
used to write the move down before i
played it and sometimes my opponent
would try to peek at my scoresheet to
get advance notice of what i'm about to
play now things have been simplified you
aren't allowed to do that anymore
so
the actual way that you move different
people up different way of moving i tend
to move just like this
pawn to e4 you want to make sure that
you leave the pieces neatly in the
center of the square so that you don't
have to keep adjusting it if you do need
to adjust a piece i'll get to that
and you press the clock
and you write down the move e
four
you could see me writing it down there
put the pen down
it's your opponent's turn
now if your opponent has not shown up to
the board and this is not going to
happen too often
uh every tournament has its own rules
about how much time has to elapse before
the game is awarded to you as a forfeit
okay so what you don't want to do you
don't want to stop the clock you don't
want to panic
generally most commonly that amount of
time is an hour so you have to wait an
entire an entire hour and when that hour
has passed you are allowed to stop the
clock generally there will be a
tournament director who watches this
unfold and who is aware that there's a
game where an opponent hasn't shown up
um
there are some tournaments that have
like a 30-minute policy
you will sometimes even have a zero
tolerance policy where you have to
arrive on time or else you'll be
forfeited but generally those are more
official tournaments
um so let's say that amount of time is
an hour let's say your opponent comes to
the board
you shake hands and you know your
opponent makes a move right
okay so that is how the game proceeds
once your opponent makes a move you
write it down
and then you start thinking now a couple
of things
um first of all
99.9 of uscf official tournaments rated
tournaments are touch move
that means something very simple if you
touch a move without saying adjust you
must move it
okay so if i touch a knight i have to
move this knight no other knight and no
other piece
what i can do is this let's say i wanted
to play knight f3
i haven't released my hand yet i am
allowed to retract that move and move
this very same knight to a different
square okay i can do this
what i cannot do
is this
let's say where my move
i go like this
i release my hand
and i put my knife back when your hand
releases the piece not when you press
the clock when your hand releases the
piece the move is made you must press
the clock this is sometimes
misunderstood but as long as your hand
remains on the piece you can move the
piece back to its initial square and
choose a different move but with that
very same piece so touch move it's a
very simple rule now if your opponent
has put a piece in at inaccurately or
not in the center of the square you are
allowed only on your move to adjust
yours or your opponent's pieces it is
acceptable to adjust your opponent's
pieces you want to make sure that you're
doing this within reason you don't want
to be obnoxious you don't want to adjust
stuff that's almost in the center of the
square you want to use this as sparingly
as possible in order not to disrupt the
flow of the game
but if you want to adjust something you
say adjust
not adjust loudly but you whisper adjust
and you can adjust your opponent's piece
or you can adjust your own piece
technically if you want to adjust more
than one piece on one turn
um
you would want to say adjust several
times that rarely happens though you
normally just want to adjust one piece
just
adjust and
people are not going to nitpick if you
say it just too quietly you're rarely
going to get it as people you want to
make sure you're saying it
if your opponent touches a piece
and it's a blunder let's say we have
some random position and let's say
moving the queen is a blunder your
opponent touches the queen
and then releases it he clearly didn't
say it just and then tries to move
another piece what do you do in the
event that a dispute like this arises
what you want to do is stop the clock
you are allowed to stop the clock only
under two conditions a you are resigning
i'll get to that later b you are calling
a tournament direction director if you
believe that your opponent has violated
the rules you do not want to engage with
your opponent this is a very common
mistake try to start talking to your
opponent during the game you agitate
other players who are playing around you
you do you want minimal contact with
your opponent during the game so if your
opponent has violated the rules you
pause the clock you raise your hand all
right i'm raising my hand
and you wait until a tournament director
comes you explain the situation and
obviously you cannot be guaranteed a
positive resolution now as i'm
describing this please understand that
disputes like this are incredibly rare i
in my chest career have had maybe one
maybe two moments when i called over the
tournament director in adult tournaments
people mostly play honorably you will
rarely see somebody touch a piece and
not move it that kind of stuff is
exceedingly rare but i want to make sure
that i'm explaining stuff just in case
people have background worries right you
never want to i think this is true of
anything if you have that background
fear uh it's going to limit the amount
of fun that you're having so i want to
make sure i'm covering all the bases so
that's what you do in case of a dispute
that's what touch move is
let me check my sheets to see what else
i want to talk about okay so the other
thing
um you do not say
check so let's let's bring black's king
to c6 so you can see it
um i think that this is a product of
hollywood and uh scholastic tournaments
but it is not customary you know
grandmasters do not say check when they
give a check so if you're giving a check
with a bishop
you simply make it like any other move
you press the clock all right i've never
said check it's not that anybody is
going to dislike you if you say check
but it's absolutely unnecessary and it
is assumed that your opponent can tell
when they are in check so
uh this is a very commonly asked
question and the answer is no you should
not announce check uh when you've
delivered a check now what about
checkmate let's say that
obviously this is a pure hypothetical
black is a king on c6 and let's say
you're moving the queen to b5 with
checkmate how do you deliver checkmate
you make it like any other move you play
queen b5 and in this case you i would
press the clock and then quietly say
checkmate and extend your hand to your
opponent or fist bump again
your opponent is probably going to
oblige it's going to be immediately
clear whether it is checkmate so that's
their you know the procedure for
delivering mate
uh it doesn't really matter
okay so other uh rules about playing
etiquette that kind of stuff so no hands
on the board that's
just to mean that you should only your
hands on the board should only be to
adjust or move pieces all right i
understand that some people who've
learned chess online you can't draw
arrows on the board and visualization
might be harder that's just something
that has to be acquired with uh with
more practice but you know you don't
want to touch squares you don't want to
touch pieces you don't want your hand in
the vicinity of the board unless you
were actually making a move
all right same with the clock that kind
of stuff you don't want to tinker with
it whatever you know
whether you fidget with already captured
pieces a lot of grandmasters do that
whether you fidget with your pen i
usually do that that's totally up to you
but you want to make sure that you're
not disrupting the flow of the game
okay to offer a drop so let's say you
wish to offer a draw the proper
procedure to offer a draw is the
following let's say you want to offer an
early draw so what you would do is you
make a move and as you're making the
move i guess it would be your move as
you're making the move you say you look
up at your opponent you say i offer a
draw you could also say draw or off or
draw
there's no formal this is what you have
to say i usually say i offer a draw and
you press the clock what is important
here it is very important to offer a
draw as you're making a move so that
your opponent can contemplate that draw
on their move what you do not want to do
is offer a draw while it's your turn if
you do that your opponent may legally
ask you to make a move
and may still accept the draw after you
make that move
okay obviously one could come up with
devil's advocate edge cases what if one
player offers a draw as they are giving
checkmate okay that kind of stuff is
never going to arise and is to be
resolved by a tournament director but
you don't want to do anything to troll
your opponent you want to only offer a
draw if you mean to offer it okay so to
offer a draw as you're making a move you
say i offer a draw and you press the
clock
to accept the draw all you have to do is
stop the clock and fist bump shake hands
whatever to decline a draw you do not
have to say anything if your opponent is
offered to draw you're playing with the
black pieces you wish to decline it you
can simply make a move and press the
clock that means
that already implies that you're
declining the draw if you want to be
polite this is what i try to do unless
the draw offer is really obnoxious like
my opponent's offering to draw a lost
position um i will say something like i
would like to play on or i wish to
continue
or let's play on any of those phrases a
perfectly acceptable way to signal to
your opponent that you've heard the
offer but that you wish to play on all
right no further talk is necessary you
don't have to share your evaluation of
the position the less you say the better
but to be polite it's totally acceptable
to say let's continue or i wish to play
on
i'd like to play on that kind of stuff
okay now this is not a fun part of the
video but i've got this question a lot
how does how does one resign
okay so the old-fashioned way of
resigning is putting your king down
that's still totally um
viable you can do that there's nothing
there's no rule against that but the way
that most grandmasters most top players
most professionals design in the modern
day is simply to stop the clock
and to fist bump or to extend your hand
to your opponent okay that signals that
you are resigning that is a very
foolproof way stopping the clock in
general unless you are stopping the
clock to raise the dispute it
essentially means that you are
uh admitting that the game is over and
you're resigning the game so if you want
to resign like magnus carlsen does he
does not resign off but when he does
magnus would stop the clock and extend
his hand but you want to be
old-fashioned you can put your king out
put your king down um you could also
just extend your hand straight away
without stopping the clock but i prefer
to stop the clock to signal to my
opponent that um you know the game the
game is over
okay what else
um have i written here um beverages yeah
so if you may have beverages at the
board uh a good you know do not put your
coffee cup on the board obviously
exercise common sense you can put it you
know a little bit away from the board
you can have coffee obviously nothing
alcoholic um soda whatever you you can
also have light food items that is
totally allowed unless you know some
special tournament and it's been
forbidden so read the rules on the
website but generally i like to bring a
granola bar
a chocolate bar something to keep
yourself going if you have a long game
again
regular etiquette applies don't be
obnoxious
it's better not to slurp try to be
discreet i what i tend to do if i
brought a banana or granola bar is to
eat it i get up from the board
um and eat it a good distance away from
my opponent that brings me to another
point yes you are allowed to get up from
the board and yes technically you can
get up on your turn you can get up on
your opponent's turn but to go to the
bathroom that's another thing that you
should do before the first round you
should find where the nearest bathroom
is uh so you don't have to waste any
time looking but the best way is you
make a move you press the clock you get
up to go to the bathroom you can also
get up to watch other games in progress
that kind of stuff
um there is no prohibition there's no
limit to the amount of times you can get
up and again you want to get up
discreetly making as little noise as
possible
um but beverages
are allowed and you know light food and
food items are allowed i once played
next to somebody who brought sushi and
it was of the particularly smelly
variety i think it was eel
let's just say that individual was not
very well well liked by people sitting
around his board so make sure you're
exercising common sense and good
judgment deciding what food to bring
um okay castling yeah so uh castling is
done normally you want to make sure
you're doing
is that you are touching your king first
you're putting it here
and you'll bring the rook round do not
touch the rook first if you touch the
rook first yes your opponent can force
you to move the rook this is very
important for older players
i i think particularly a lot of older
russian players they tend to move the
rook first i don't really know why
but uh i think even anatoly karpov
former world champion was
had an incident like this where he moved
the rook first make sure you're moving
the king and moving the rook away
the other thing is that you want to do
everything with one hand if possible all
right
technically what's prohibited is moving
with one hand and then pressing the
clock with the other not that you would
necessarily do that
but you want to make sure you're doing
everything with one hand that simplifies
the process all right
if you want to castle with two hands
sometimes in a blitz game you can do
this but what you do not want to do is
have one hand moving the other hand
pressing the clock that looks weird i'm
not sure that there's an actual rule
against it but it is highly frowned upon
make sure that you're moving with one
hand there's no move that you need two
hands for all right
um
so that's just an etiquette thing
all right what else do i have declined
draw we talked about resigning we talked
about castling beverages getting up
yeah so i have
flag fall that's easy to explain and
then three-fold repetition okay so let's
say your opponent is lost on time all
right one very important thing
there are tournaments that have a sudden
death time control in tournaments that
do not a sudden death time control just
means that a certain amount of time is
added after a certain uh move number is
played for example it's usually move 30
or move 40. some clocks they if
the sudden uh death time control move
has been made they will go down to zero
before adding the additional 30 moves
make sure that you're well acquainted
with
what number move you're at and that's
why it's so important to keep notation
carefully
and the type of clock that you have all
right you don't want to call flag if
your opponent hasn't actually lost on
time but if your opponent has lost on
time it's going to show zeroes it is
your responsibility and yours alone
to indicate that your opponent is lost
on time you want to do is you want to
look over and say time
and your opponent will most likely
acknowledge it if they do not
acknowledge it then you stop the clock
and you call the td but again that's not
gonna happen
um it's pretty rare to lose on time but
it does happen so to indicate that your
opponent is lost on time you whisper
time and
handshake the game is over
threefold repetition this is actually
important i think this is very commonly
misunderstood even by very good and very
experienced players
so
as some of you probably know if a
position repeats three times the same
position has to repeat three times in
order for one side to be able to claim
the draw now let's say that you wish to
claim three time repetition and i won't
go into the actual
um sort of intricacies of the rule
itself i'm going to assume that you know
what threefold repetition is
now let's say that you've repeated blah
blah blah
and you have you look at your scoresheet
you can inspect and you say wait a
second if i move my bishop to e3
then the position will be repeated three
times it doesn't matter how it was
reached it has to be just the same
position
and let's say that a draw wins through
the tournament so you're feeling happy
and you play bishop e3 and then you
press the clock and then you say three
fold repetition and you put your hand
out your opponent does not have to shake
it nor does he have to acknowledge that
a three-fold repetition has occurred
so must do is if you have determined
that a certain move causes three-fold
repetition do not make the move what you
have to do is you have to write it down
clearly on your scoresheet stop the
clock
and call the tournament director over at
which point you have to show the
tournament director on your scoresheet
that the same position has been reached
three times and normally your opponent
won't dispute it but if he does you want
to make sure that you've kept notation
carefully and then you want to you want
to show the tournament director the move
you're about to play
and tell them that it reaches three-fold
repetition all right at which point uh
the tv will generally take your
scoresheet and look over it and verify
or
if it's a particularly controversial
case uh he might lead you and your
opponent over to another board where you
actually make the moves out on the board
and and verify that the repetition has
occurred that's happened to me
but at no
at all
you know at no time never do you
actually want to make that move on the
board and press the clock or make the
move and stop the click when a move is
made you have forfeited your right to
claim that repetition has occurred a lot
of painful losses have been inflicted
this way so to summarize three-fold
repetition do not make the move write it
down stop the clock call the tournament
director
okay
so
that's about all i have in terms of the
game itself now when the game ends on
your scoresheet there will generally be
options for white one or black one you
want to circle it
um it's very customary to sign the score
sheets you want to sign your own score
sheet and what you'll often see is your
opponent will be handing you their
scoresheet you'll be handing your
opponent yours and you will sign your
name the appropriate column if you're
black where it you know gives the black
name sign of your scoresheet basically
says that yes uh you agree that the game
had the result that it did okay it's all
customary you don't have to sign the
scoresheet that's not a rule but it's
good custom to do so
at that point you want to get up and in
most tournaments it is your
responsibility to mark the result now if
you're new to chess you've not played
over the board chess this is
particularly important because a lot of
anguish is caused this way
remember that pairing sheet in the
tournament hall that is generally the
also the official results sheet so you
want to come up to that sheet and
indicate the result let's go back to our
pairing sheet from earlier which of
course i have
summarily misplaced there it is let's
say that you are carlson and you're
playing curry steph curry is higher
rated than magnus carlsen and carlson
has one what do you do
you put one
where your name is and zero where your
opponent's name is you will see you will
see where other people have marked it
you can sometimes it's before the name
sometimes it's after if a draw was made
it's in the game between smith and jones
you just put half hat
very importantly
this generally will not happen but even
if you your opponent has told you that
they will mark the result you still want
to come up and verify because yes
sometimes by mistake by mistake the
result is marked the wrong way and it is
your responsibility to make sure that
the result is marked the right way and
in most cases unless you're playing a
tournament in europe in europe you
generally submit your score sheets to
the td and they mark the result but even
in europe when in doubt go up to the
pairing sheet and make sure that the
result is correctly marked marked
and um
that's about it the last thing i was
going to talk about here is
uh claiming prizes i think we finished
with everything over the board so i can
tilt the camera back up and
we can make
all right
i think we're good oh let me just tilt
it up just a little bit more
all right i think this is good okay
uh so
last uh technical thing claiming prizes
so if you have won a monetary prize
uh after the tournament there is
generally
uh that evening there is a tournament
director that writes that writes checks
or there's you know they will announce
how to claim your price sometimes they
mail it out and you have to give your
address whatever it is the tournament
director at the start of a round will
announce how to collect your prizes
don't worry about that
but uh sometimes you'll have to provide
your information if you have to leave a
tournament
uh before price the prize collection you
what you should do is you should always
alert the tournament director give them
your home address and generally a check
will be mailed to you in due time but
don't worry about it that kind of stuff
happens pretty reliably in american
tournaments you will get your prize
if you have won one
and um
that's basically all i was going to talk
about now
uh i'm sure that there's a lot of stuff
that i missed
and for this video specifically i will
be reading the comments very carefully
so if you have questions please leave
them in the comments i will do my very
best to answer them but i hope that this
incredibly rambly
amateurish video did help astonish your
fear your fears to to some extent about
playing over the board chess and i hope
i was able to explain away uh explain
some of these uh thorny thorny moments
and uh things that perhaps were
disawaiting you from from trying your
hand over the board chest which i think
everybody should now most importantly is
just to exercise common sense to look
around at how others are doing it and if
you you know if you behave well you do
stuff that you would do in real life
uh you know you're generally not going
to attract any uh negative attention at
the tournament uh and when in doubt ask
the tournament director use google and
um use the comment section so i hope you
enjoyed this video i will put the links
to the tournament set and the clock that
i recommend in the
description and i wish you the very best
of luck in your over-the-board chess
career thank you for watching and i'll
see you in the next video